[Música]
me gustaría compartirles una frase que
la primera vez que la escuché me marco
la escuche desde pequeñito se la escuché
a mi padre la realidad siempre supera la
ficción he podido comprobar a nivel
personal y a nivel profesional que es
una máxima que siempre se cumple estoy
convencido que muchos de ustedes estarán
totalmente de acuerdo conmigo a nivel
personal recuerdo la primera vez que fui
padre algunos amigos me decían ni te
imaginas lo que te viene encima
prepárate no sabes dónde te has metido
yo pensaba que exagerados acostumbrado a
vernos de visita con los niños pequeños
hoy cuándo termina una conferencia
termino una clase y alguna asistente me
pregunta oiga profe usted tiene familia
lo niego rotundamente no tiene familia
digo no que tiene una empresa de
demolición la realidad siempre supera la
ficción si nos vamos al terreno
profesional estamos escuchando el
concepto de la industria 4.0 la cuarta
revolución industrial esto no es nuevo
para empezar si somos precisos
deberíamos hablar de la cuarta ola de
innovación y tecnología y la historia de
la humanidad las cuatro grandes son las
tecnológicas las cuatro grandes
revoluciones industriales han tenido un
patrón de comportamiento similar han
tenido tres elementos en común que se
han repetido
en primer lugar profundos cambios
tecnológicos e innovaciones en segundo
lugar profundos cambios sociales y en
tercer lugar nuevos modelos de
relaciones de oportunidades y por
extensión de negocios si nos centramos
en nuestra actual cuarta revolución
industrial sobre que se construye cuáles
son los tres pilares fundamentales de
esta revolución industrial internet de
las cosas big data e inteligencia
artificial si hoy estamos descubriendo
por primera vez estos conceptos
estaríamos diez años por detrás de la
realidad del mercado realmente
estaríamos en el paleolítico tecnológico
la realidad siempre supera la ficción
me gustaría compartirles una noticia que
seguramente más de uno de ustedes pudo
leer en su momento personalmente me
gusta mucho el deporte me gusta el
fútbol prometo no torturar a aquellos
que no sean muy futboleros saben que el
último mundial de fútbol se celebró en
rusia y ganó la selección francesa el
mundial anterior se celebró en brasil y
lo ganó la selección alemana de fútbol
pocas fechas antes del comienzo del
último mundial de rusia
apareció la siguiente noticia a la
prensa la vigente campeona del mundo la
selección alemana de fútbol presume
públicamente de haber utilizado
herramientas de big data para el diseño
de la estrategia ganadora del mundial de
fútbol de brasil lo vemos impresionante
como son los alemanes elvis que el big
data hombre claro sino con el big data
cómo van a ganar el mundial realmente no
sabemos el alcance tecnológicamente de
esta noticia pero analicemos la por un
momento el mundial de brasil hace más de
cuatro años los mundiales se preparan
cada cuatro años y seguramente el
desarrollo tecnológico tendría un par de
años esa noticia tiene como poco 10 años
tecnológicos o estamos en la punta de
lanza o estamos una década por detrás
la realidad siempre supera la ficción
hemos comentado de un instante que la
cuarta revolución industrial no es
futuro es presente nos acompaña la
última década donde está el futuro que
es lo que viene la clave la tenemos en
el concepto de o la ola de innovación y
ola tecnológica por definición que es
una ola una sucesión de ondas que genera
el mar existen tres tipos de olas olas
de traslación aquellas que llevan el
agua de un lugar a otro son las que
conocemos habitualmente las que vemos en
la playa las que rompen en la orilla
segundo tipo de olas las olas de
rotación no se ven habitualmente se
producen por debajo de la superficie y
suelen tener forma circular tercer tipo
de ola los tsunamis la fuerza bruta de
la naturaleza la metáfora de olas
tecnológicas o las de innovación se
utiliza para que nos hagamos una idea
del impacto que pueden tener las
siguientes olas tecnológicas de
innovación en las personas y en la
humanidad
entonces si hoy estoy la cuarta ola
tecnológica y es una sucesión de ondas
en algún momento llegará la siguiente no
es que vaya a llegar ya está en marcha
la quinta ola tecnológica ya existe se
calcula que será cinco veces más potente
que la actual la tecnológica tiempo
estimado de impacto cinco años
espectacular
pero volvemos al origen del problema son
sucesiones de ondas y después qué pasará
habrá una sexta la tecnológica ya está
en marcha la sexta ola tecnológica ya
existe incluso algunos otros ya han
bautizado human to brand lo que
significarán las organizaciones las
instituciones para las personas y su
impacto en la sociedad espectacular
impresionante potencia de esta ola diez
veces más potente que la quinta ola
tecnológica tiempo estimado de impacto
15 años sin palabras que sucederá en la
sexta la tecnológica nuestras casas no
tendrán paredes no habrá tabiques que
habrá grandes paneles de cristal
realmente no serán paneles de cristal
serán grandes pantallas de leds con una
resolución mínima de 16 k nuestra
vivienda estará gobernada por
inteligencia artificial cada vez que
regresemos a casa la inteligencia
artificial nos hará un reconocimiento
facial un reconocimiento del iris
identificar a nuestro estado emocional
las experiencias las vivencias que día
pasamos y en tiempo real hará una
ambientación de nuestra vivienda
un bosque frondoso una apuesta de sobre
el templo de tanna lote en tailandia
porque es un momento especialmente
emotivo para nosotros o incluso
tendremos la posibilidad de acondicionar
cada estancia en función de quien vive
en ellas impresionante salvaje
espectacular la realidad siempre supera
la ficción y entonces qué sucede ahora
pues que todas estas sucesiones de ondas
nos van a impactar alguno de ustedes
pensar a hoy sólo traer buenas noticias
irónicamente no es una mala noticia es
una muy buena noticia es una oportunidad
el objetivo de estas reflexiones es
hacernos pensar de forma diferente qué
papel queremos tener tenemos la
posibilidad de ser actores o actrices
principales que pueden surfear que
pueden disfrutar esas olas de innovación
y de tecnología o preferimos quedarnos
estáticos y que el tsunami pase por
encima de nosotros
pero hemos olvidado una cuestión muy
importante una pregunta clave donde está
el mayor desarrollo tecnológico del
universo dónde está la mayor
concentración de tecnología donde está
el mayor potencial de innovación en el
universo
la respuesta es muy sencilla en cada uno
de ustedes en las personas en su cerebro
y cuál es la herramienta la magnífica
herramienta para dinamizar todo ello la
actitud que cada uno de ustedes adopta
esta es la clave el gran reto científico
cuál es conocer el verdadero potencial
de esta magnífica maquinaria de
precisión que es el cerebro cerebro pero
por qué porque es el eje dinamizador de
las siguientes son las tecnológicas y de
innovación esta es la esencia pero con
un objetivo fundamental situar a las
personas en el centro de las olas de
innovación y tecnología pero con
objetivo más importante generar o
contribuir a una sociedad mejor y más
eficaz esta es la esencia este es el
objetivo fundamental
me gustaría que algunos de los
asistentes pudiera responder a esta
pregunta como imagináis como imaginas lo
que vivirás en esa futura hora
tecnológica alguien quiere compartirlo
por favor por favor no lo digas por muy
espectacular que sea tu idea la realidad
siempre supera a la ficción muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]